hello and welcome to this video playing
Shandy kiya got this again game popular
somehow his opening SHINee Kia who is
that pretty high ratings all over the
place okay I don't have such a great
recipe against that she Corinne so I'm
playing this this setup here cannot be
particularly bad but it's also not very
ambitious
what aims for cars but type of structure
which should be a roughly equal
[Music]
I wonder if f5 is an idea for black eye
when I've got I've got maybe three or so
looks wrong
and yet the minority attack there is no
ponen c6 but oh this should be okay
right I should have some play against c7
here in this position yeah just Queen
here problem
[Music]
no chewy once turn on i-25 so taking
looks like the thing to do
yeah see porn is just a weakness
doesn't look comfortable for black
Knight g5 is also an idea but he has
he's God Bishop a5
I wonder if Bishop b3 is good but you
know a move that is simple and okay it's
just this one training this
I can also take with a night yeah
I know mind to put in hydroxy six and
now we actually trade everything down
this is fantastic
that has all the makings of a nightmare
what no okay I mean this is not winning
yet or something where it is a very good
position so let's see
context is not bad
rook takes the stronger oh that's a good
move I should have played a four
I should play d4 earlier absolutely hmm
hmm I should have played f4 that would
have made a big difference I think after
we have inserted a four that would have
been a strategically almost winning
position and now it is not that clear
[Music]
it's still good but as the difference
between winning and good check
check-check
yeah it's very difficult for black to
hand disposition
still
[Music]
what is the cleanest way to do that if I
take it there that's two connected pesos
that should be strong check-check
time warning
just going to get a new queen check
check check
black resigns okay
so that I'm just a bit angry that I
didn't play for because that would have
prevented anything and I always had the
opportunity to do so that wasn't a very
time critical situation
yeah I think this must be a roughly
equal position this is confirmed by the
engine but I'm not so sure about this
here it starts to get a little bit a
little bit problematic for him as the
c-pawn will be permanently a permanent
problem you have to be six I thought it
was it was just a terrible position and
I maybe had to I don't know the engine
plates that as well no no no it doesn't
be six Wow
do you have to know it is just not good
anyway our here's five takes f6 yeah
okay there is a good defense yeah here
white is just a bit better and this is
still a bit weak but that was a good
defense
so maybe 95 wasn't the most precise
movie I am Queen B 3 first we need for
first okay and I should I should
actually do I should play a form
somewhere here just to make sure that
this counter play isn't happening
I should do that basically every move if
you imagine the same position
like yeah he always has a four he has to
do that and this was no he played it so
if we just imagine I go here he takes
takes rook e8 and I go II form and this
position here I can improve forever King
here if I've d5 King up it's very
awkward for black
he is playing without this pawn the
engine just gives gives me a slight
advantage but I don't I don't buy it
I think why does it look better him
long-term okay this is not so great but
I have to do it it's better than
allowing this a for business here you
get some definite counter play
yeah maybe c6 didn't that didn't turn
out so well okay can take and play see
five so maybe I should have taken first
then check c5 hmm this is the kind of
move that you shy away from because you
see that yeah but probably nothing
happens here that's the engine in
decades
[Music]
check check check check
yeah now it gets very ugly yeah this is
a panic move but it's it's not grating I
have this can try to invade or use the
pass on its however not necessary to
you'll get into this just panic mode
yeah definitely no no the points just
just go check check check
promote we had tough strategic game but
I should have definitely played a for
that something that to keep in mind
somehow this motif that all of a sudden
he breaks out with the rook okay
thanks for watching